so we are told let's count by tens and
we go 10
20 blank 40 50 60 70 80 90 000.
what number did we miss pause the video
what number did we miss right over here
well if we're counting by tens we would
go 10
30. 40 50 60 70 80 90 100 so we're
missing 30. so which choice right over
here has 30 well if we scroll down a
little bit we see right there that is
our choice let's do another example
so here
we are asked which 10 frames show 20 and
a 10 frame is just a fancy word for one
of these blocks of these frames that
have 10 objects in it you can see it
right over here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. so
which of these 10 frames show 20.
well 20 is two groups of 10. so this is
10 and then 20. so that's 20 right over
there choice b is 10 20 30 40. choice c
is 10 20 30. so we could feel good about
choice a
here we're told drag the 10 frames into
the box to make 40. so let's see here
this is 10
right over there then we get another 10
gets us to 20
then another 10 gets us to 30
and then finally another 10 gets us to
40. 10 20 30 40. we're done